there is no debate I will continue to
say what I said a year ago especially
there's a lot of you weren't here this
is what actually works creatively on the
Internet and the internet really matters
you got your prospective happy don't you
want to be happy
[Music]
you
[Music]
one of the best parts of being CEO of
this company last four months is way
more one-on-one meetings have happened
and I can't tell you how much as a macro
that makes me feel better because it's
not only the hundred people I've seen
the last 120 days it's also the two to
three that they've affected by the
meetings I've had internally and I think
it's been collectively good and I'd like
to triple down on more of that
[Music]
everybody was really looking forward to
this so excited to be here
I just couldn't encourage a more
collaborative culture of asking
questions I'm trying to create the
permission for somebody who's on their
first week to reach out to the most
senior creative gonna ask her him you
know hey what was this about or how did
you get there so I think that's how we
take this meeting and take it from a
moment in time and make it actually
living and breathing which is
disproportionately the most important
thing that we can accomplish as a
company so please heed that let's talk
about bbm volume model was very
important to me to establish about a
year ago for a lot of reasons but if you
play all the chess moves it's because
when I hear that term I don't think that
that's a thing in the way that I and we
have positioned it I think it really
means best-in-class digital creative
work which unless you're not living in
the world I'm sure you realize the
Internet is real and the dynamics on
that platform continue to inform us in
our thinking and our behavior and I
wanted and we continue need to be the
best in the world as communicators on
that platform from the horse's mouth
with no hyperbole or in my normal
disproportionately optimistic kind of
DNA we are wildly ahead of pace with
volume model interjected in this company
for us to be going from a place of you
know eleven months ago standing in front
of the company and saying here's this
thing and let there be no confusion for
the ones in here that don't know me as
well it was not well-received
meaning mentally like everybody thought
this is cute but I'm gonna do my own
[ __ ] right or this is theoretical but
this isn't real or most of all which is
the great mistake of companies my
customers not going to like this you
know we talk a lot about our job a
strategy creative account people is to
say the right things move our clients in
the right place but the reality is it's
a very tough job I have enormous empathy
for account people in their day-to-day
interactions we're getting punched in
the face verbally by account the clients
and things of that nature and you know
and so
I am so excited about how far along we
are most of all internally to go from
90% of the organization not being bought
in to 50 is a lot of advancement in 11
months
it just means half the company still
doesn't know what it is
believe in it or things of that nature
which means we have a lot of work to do
because we have no shot with the clients
or the world unless we internally
understand there is no debate I will
continue to say what I said a year ago
especially because a lot of you weren't
here this is what actually works
creatively on the internet and the
internet really matters let me guys
[Applause]
[Music]
that's the brilliance of a volume
creative model the reason I'm smart and
have all these insights is because I've
created a content machine that led to me
listening it looks like I'm talking it
led to me listening right it is crazy
it's a good one I made sure Dustin
caught it you know all the talking has
led to a level of listening that gives
me such profound consumer insights I
will push everybody to podcasts like you
would not believe even more than video
because I think video is a bigger mental
and infrastructural jump for many I love
podcasts because of the following you do
a podcast you film the podcast which
gives you video you get the guests
audience when they're a guest because
they're gonna promote it bringing you
awareness the first person can be the
[ __ ] third generational guy who's 58
who owns the boat company in town that's
been crushing for years and when you
email him on LinkedIn or his email and
say hey John do you want to be the first
guest on the Boca business podcast
answers yes cuz John's not being asked
by anybody to be out of podcast got it
and then literally the contents of piece
of cakes so John tell us about how you
got started so job what's happening now
how's Boca changed in the last like
you're [ __ ] 40 minutes done before
and started asking for questions and
going to sleep for the first eight years
of my career I didn't have a team so the
way I would have done it it's like that
like I would have to had my iPhone on
the table and recorded it and then
literally posted the raw [ __ ] video
on LinkedIn so like you know people
again being the messenger a lot of these
a lot of these things right now scares
me because I have a level of notoriety
now leveraged infrastructure but I got
here by doing what I'm telling you to do
thank you you're welcome
thanks guys hi folks welcome to the grit
leadership podcast where we try and
build better leaders and teammates
through gratitude relationships
innovation and teamwork what is it that
helps y'all focus on that and you know
get back to Center or find that
gratitude you know every day I actually
go with gratitude guilt and scaring
myself so I've been thinking a lot
lately about my mindset and like today I
came back to the office after being away
for two weeks which is very unusual for
me which means I had an enormous amount
of headaches on my plate and no matter
how bad anything is I always go to a
place of well what if my mom got killed
like what if right now I got a phone
call from a hysterical sister saying
mom's dead she was murdered
right and for some reason I do that
fifty five times a year sometimes it's
my mom sometimes it's my kids and my
wife driving and get hammy but but this
unbelievable ability to actually feel
enormous life-changing deep painful pain
that just in seconds looks everything in
such basic perspective that I don't know
there's nothing else you know what I
love by the way is I'm just bouncing and
it was awesome New York City when I walk
in New York City this always runs
through my mind it's a grid and I have
800,000 like I always feel like I'm
funny like I don't walk the same way
ever like I have to go somewhere
I'm always doing different [ __ ] like
going three avenues then two streets
that like I don't know why it's probably
my entrepreneurial chaotic way whereas
like my dad walks the same exact way
every time and I every time I do it if I
run into a stranger a friend or
something I'm always like that's so cool
it's so [ __ ] cool that I could have
went one more Avenue and then took it
and like basically I think we're
completely not in control of anything
which kind of literally makes me feel in
control of everything that's right
you